c'est une grande semaine qui commencera
lundi pour les couturiers et aussi pour
les mannequins les collections des buts
et elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses
années après années aujourd'hui ils sont
26 les couturiers à nous présenter leurs
dernières créations 3000 robe qui seront
examinés sur toutes les coutures par
environ un millier d'acheteurs venus du
monde entier
en même temps le palais galliera va nous
montrer deux siècles d'élégance
française alors les modèles du passé à
ceux de demain je vous propose en
compagnie de france roche un tout petit
voyage celui ci vous permettra de
découvrir les nouveautés les plus
extrêmes de la mode
79 objet de vanité une saison de
curiosité dix ans plus tard en fin
d'études historiques
la robe à la mode passe en 20 ans de
l'état de parures et vol à celui de
document sociologique la tunique à la
française
la robe à l'antique la crinoline comme
la mini jupe on en est la royauté deux
empires iii révolution et menthe
république aussi inséparable de leur
temps que fleur de lys abeilles d'or ou
style art déco au palais galliera
l'exposition de siècle d'élégance
française nous fait voyager des paniers
les marques 18e au ski des sportifs du
20e tandis que dans 26 ateliers de haute
couture ont fini les 3000 robe qui
seront la cuvée 79 de la mode française
les caprices des faits maires
deviendront donc un jour images d'une
décade les chiffons se transformeront en
reliques
mais quel vêtement attireront un jour au
musée de l'an 2000 ces pantalons étrange
de ce qui apparaît lee lepage qui
tiennent du fus talent de grand papa à
la culotte du zouave
cette redingote sur habits noirs de
christian dior qui semblent empruntés à
vidocq et aux mystères de paris
où cette sultane 1925 toujours dior mais
aérodynamique sortie d'un ballet russe
cardin a une autre idée pour la femme
qui travaille le pantalon court de
coulisses autres pantalons courts de
torrents tu sais la fille du cheikh qui
auraient pratiqué l'économie d'énergie
sur le tissu pour les grands froids paco
rabanne préconise le tissu des grands
shows le tissu ignifugé des
vulcanologues fleuri pour la pluie ou
réchauffés de fourrure pour aller passer
un week end hiver sur la lune avec
ungaro c'est la ligne punk mais de luxe
berlin 1927 kabarett près du coup franc
steendam jupe à carreaux choquant bottes
lacées de spécialistes corsage pailletée
à manches de dentelle voilette et un
oiseau empaillé au cou regard noir de
rigueur d'autres audaces pour les
réveillons sans complexe une dalle isc
sortie d'un hollywood d'avant-guerre que
matinée de casino de paris et ce par a +
japonais style paquet cadeau pour arbre
de noël de schiaparelli
enfin il fallait y penser car d'un l'a
fait là chaussettes tricotées rouge
employé comme corsage noué avec une
cravate s'est terminée par une jupe
paulhan de penderies en grenier de
grenier un stand de la foire aux puces
quel vêtement atterrira au musée pour
briller un jour doucement à côté des
robes de duchesse de petite fille modèle
oui
on peut effectivement se poser la
question ne va nous découvrirons
peut-être les secrets de la mode sage
celle que nous verrons dans la rue l'été
prochain
l'an prochain plutôt voilà cette édition
est maintenant terme